foreign
good evening everybody and welcome
okay let's challenge for the safe
it's usually available to play
that would be an interesting match
actually
okay feather save is done this is gonna
be a fun one
I don't like facing the Pet Shop I'm
gonna play Glock
foreign
yeah that is correct
let's go to three
okay typically y goes Knight D2 and F4
okay it could go F5 could go F5
I don't know Knight F3 makes sense
Knight C4
okay let's go another third back
no 92 gotta speed up a little bit here
yeah the production quality for the
melwater tournaments really is amazing
okay I want to take off the pawn I'm not
sure what he's aiming for here he does
have the Knight G4 but no I just take
okay let's just develop
developer rookie one okay yeah once
before obviously
could play C3
I don't see why not let's play C3 to
stop B4 you can go rookie one
okay let's get the Rook into the game
he's probably gonna go Bishop C7 would
be my guess
D5 okay we'll go E5
okay
okay let's go D4
[Music]
let's go here
let's go to G1
yeah he's trying to blockade everything
here which makes sense
okay let's go push buff one
I kind of want to trade this bishop off
but it's hard to do it well he actually
found an amazing regrouping
um
let me do this
I remember this queen up is in here
foreign
91.
okay and we gotta get the queen out of
there
I don't know what to do
a knight of two
two
I want to go Knight G4
he's gonna go 905. let's let's just sack
this one
no those probably terrible
yeah it was definitely terrible but
practically it's interesting
Derek F1 next
um
foreign
but I take it
I'm gonna do them here
yeah that was a bad technique in the end
but I knew I would flag him so I wasn't
really focused on finding the best move
thank you Kevin Richardson
that is a very he likes these offbeat
lines
I don't know it makes sense to go E5
since he's given me the chance to do so
thank you Grande
okay yeah this is boring I I really I
hoped he wouldn't do that
I'm not in the mood for an end game
um
95 okay but
yeah let's go rookie
probably shouldn't do that but it is
what it is thank you why blacko for the
prime
[Music]
yeah he does go 95 I thought I go see
yeah crap I should have gone
should have maybe gone E4 here first
um I can go E4 I can go Bishop F5 and E4
I can go Bishop F5 Knight Ace let's
start with Bishop F5
okay definitely I should go E4 this is
like a must
[Music]
probably bad
hmm
let's go H6 because I didn't want him to
stick a bishop money seven at the end
okay one's Knight F4
oh crap I should have gone to the other
Rook I was very sloppy
that was very very very sloppy yeah we
should take
yeah
I relinquished a lot of the advantage
here I think
hmm
[Music]
yeah no this is not gonna cut it
I don't see a threat oh he wants Knight
F4
let's go here
[Music]
okay I think I it's okay to take
[Music]
I messed this up but I'm not exactly
sure where
feels like I messed it up
[Music]
okay
wait they should see
wait doesn't this isn't this a coach for
me
yeah Knight F4 I thought about
we got some gems in the chat I think as
always this is like where the GM's hang
out
I'm super proud of that actually
um
oh it gets lucky here
wow
[Music]
all right
okay we gotta move
wait no king of two I can take
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you ever next thank you glitter
no as I'm not to live
foreign
he was up a lot of time you should have
won that I think
no this is the Glock system this is
actually a legit opening
okay I guess I'll go here
once D5 PM I didn't get anything
just go back play for equality
oh God wait maybe there's a sack
yeah I've played him a couple times
playing them a few times
let's get this move out we should play
something different because I'm I'm not
succeeding in the glove
and this position is really bad maybe
Knight d1c3
try to solidify a little bit
I guess
no not if
really
oh crap it doesn't work yeah
oh
I have to say
thank you Jesse for appreciate it
my pleasure
is Ram thank you
foreign
to hold this
he's so quick in these intense middle
games
it's uncanny
now what is this
what is this move
I'm playing for tricks
yeah this is
okay Knight G3 it's not horrendous but
doesn't look good either
um
okay I think this is Forest
I don't know this does not look that
oh rookie six
and I miss that
I guess I go here yeah it just has this
I missed your I forgot I could do that
okay
this is over
no it's very important
buddy I thought he'd already let me off
the hook but he didn't
oh oh I meant to play
wait
wait
Oh I thought I was I had some so many
ideas
foreign
yeah okay
I feel like I had no chances that game
be much faster much more active in the
opening
this line Knight 97
don't remember I think
I think this is the move
thank you Lewis as
I know there's H5 but I don't
remember where
I think it's now
who knows what the move is I guess here
I don't think I played for the seven
notice here versus the world so
you know I might be misremembering
or did he maybe he did I don't know
no he maybe did he he did beat me yeah
he's he's a very tough economy I've
never been able to play him for some
reason
something about his style just drives me
crazy
he plays incredibly fast but somehow
never gives up on accuracy
it's insane I don't know why he's not
higher rated
did he give see car a lot of trouble he
actually is one of the toughest
opponents for Hikaru
historically like yukara struggled
against him a lot
okay I see that he has a bnba but I have
King D7 there are even castles
except for the SEC yeah
but I'm talking more apps for the SEC
foreign
I should definitely go like Bishop B6 I
think if I shake
and Bishop B6 this makes sense
I mean we're also really good friends so
it's fun it's fun to play to play
friends
crap this is what he does it's just
Relentless and I should have of course
gotten G6 and I'm much better he just
played for tricks there
okay let's go here
you played for tricks and he caught me
okay still still complicated oh no it's
a fork
yeah wow
okay I have to sack the exchange this is
lost
too many one move wonders this game
foreign
thought I actually have some chances
here
I should have gotten Bishop D4
okay here
should be a draw
that's not gonna be easy
um
uh
oh 100 Bishop E3 oh
that's why I played D4 actually
oh that was a tough one
still not satisfactory I mean I just got
lucky
do you speak mostly Russian or English
when converting the bilingual Russian I
mean there aren't that many like super
bilingual Russian players there's not a
lot of people like me
um we're fluent in both but obviously
Russian if it's first I speak in
whichever first language
that that person
yeah the move here is B5 but very very
few people know that of course he does
wait can I go E4 anyway
for some reason I've forgotten
okay usually what I do is 95.50 but this
is bad for white don't do it anyway this
is the only thing I know
foreign
this is not not impressive for white at
all
Queen H3
ning some stuff
um
I know this is an idea
okay now I know the engine
likes to take and go F4
I know the engine likes this move and
the Knight before carving out the square
how do I know that yeah caught
right-handed
okay did I have laundry yeah I did okay
wait
um
did wonder but
maybe I can go here 93 C3
yes Knight F5 there he goes F5 right
away okay he doesn't he trust me a
little bit
excuse me
oh crap he's gonna go at four isn't he
hmm
wow age down totally paralyzed
incredible
there must be a move here
the hell
this is weird
I'm just dead here or what
I don't see a defense to F4
problem
all right this F5 idea is crazy
wow
I mean queen D4 I take so it's not clear
he does go for it I didn't think this
was that obvious but okay let's see what
he found
okay just face positionally
I don't think is that dangerous
if I don't blunder
yeah Vladimir likes these types of ideas
what
was that
um
trying to flag me
and I blundered
yeah
I don't have time
he's gonna find me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh no
no
oh [ __ ]
did everything to win that game and then
I got mated
yeah I allowed rugby too I would have
won if I just didn't lose my mind
yeah once he took B2 it was over
okay I guess it's fair given the last
game
[Music]
yeah it took way too long after he
didn't take my Bishop
foreign
I mean
yeah
it's flag flag flag every game
let's go here I'm trying to play faster
he's just unbelievable tricky
honestly crazy
every move is some sort of a trick
here
I don't really see the danger just yet
a lot of tricks here but his Center is
pretty weak
wait he played Rook C6 and she said you
want this
right what really that works I guess it
works
I guess it works
no way to defend F7 other than to play
the super passive move which I have to
play I can't allow Queen F7 that's
weights too too dangerous now I'm oh he
goes there
probably this is winning
um
average D6 Maybe
wait I don't I don't believe this
must be a defense I see what he wants
foreign
Knight F7 Rook D7
hanging by a thread
I think he has the planet of seven let's
see another move
foreign
yeah that's what I thought it would do
I'm definitely much worse I think
from a practical standpoint this is
almost indefensible unless I can flag
him
I gotta get her pieces into the game I
don't even care about any of the puns
oh Queen d925
so fast and this is unreal
free move 94.
but sometimes he gets sloppy
that's his thing he gets very sloppy
there we go
foreign
occasionally when he doesn't he's just
Unstoppable
okay we're gonna okay Knight C6
uh this line yeah so it's like a
weird kind of reverse perk where he's at
the tempo
and trying to play faster
do I have beef with anybody in the chess
community no I do not not that I know
maybe somebody has a beef with me
Knight D7 pre-moves
we do not have a Discord I do not have a
Discord
there's a Discord that's unofficial but
I have zero association with it
and I'm not responsible for what happens
within it
well the beef with hairstyle it goes
without saying that I would beef with
her I mean that's a massive beef right
there
except he's vegetarians so
I have a tofu with Hess
um okay that was bad
it is his birthday today yes
but I don't care about that because I
have a beef with him
thank you Nixon Fitzpatrick appreciate
it
okay nice okay
[Music]
um
how does he manage to play so quickly
his positions I it takes me a while to
just figure out what's happening
look at this speed
the movie takes two seconds
but I think I'm actually doing okay here
Rook ac1
um
I don't know
988
oh it's gonna go Knight C7 what am I
thinking
yeah just getting it completely
outplayed
[Music]
okay Bishop F1 stopping ip5
C5 wait C5 I can take and take
he's gonna play it now
then I guess I have Knight F3 and stuff
yeah takes
2494-92 Bishop C4
wait what was I thinking I thought the
Knight was hanging
back
to seven Knight C3
foreign
[Music]
foreign
oh my gosh they're here what's happening
oh my gosh
giraffe
foreign
what a game
interesting game
every cargo like oh Mike God done let's
see yeah thank you whoa I almost played
Bush before they get low on Cindy and
Ace midman
or no Espress Steve
yeah this freaking line
there should be three that's the quiet
line but now I have this
it does isn't it
yes
oh my God
okay what am I doing
I'm already busted
ham and Ty let's go here no no no no no
no no
terminal oh my gosh
I'm blundering left and right here
here trying to drum up some counter play
oh God
yeah I thought I saw that move
oh Jim Donald Trump welcome welcome
welcome to the chat
oh my gosh it takes it that works
doesn't it I mean it's an easy move but
it's impressive
but does it actually work is the
question
I guess it does wait I have Queen F2
Pawn down end game there
is an HD screen oh my God
what the [ __ ] Knight G3 is 4. no that's
ridiculously lucky line
oh my God that is that is honestly
absurd
I mean it just gets very fortunate
no defense there must be a move here
let's think
what about this
no Queen G5 he takes it
no this doesn't this doesn't actually
help I think but it's in a very nice
move
the thing is it doesn't have an easy way
to study me
this is where my lack of time really
hurts me
okay G3 I have Knight G3
then I send a position but
okay very unclear have we got a nice
scissors
okay after that okay
this is my bedroom because
let me know what's wrong with me right
now
okay check
here check here here and I win I think
I'm winning
oh my God sir I'm winning
yeah
oh my God
okay wait I'm up a full Rook
Lemon Thai
lemon tie up the full room
the problem with Vladimir scene it's
never over with him he literally will
find something anywhere
he'll play Knight D6 here I know for
this if so well
why won't you play night launch of
Vladimir
now I'll take okay
and he will resign very good very good
okay so calm the freak down
yeah
is
calculation Bush League tactics
it would be three
because there were I mean that that is a
lot logical logical move in prop round
it moves this goes Center gives me ice
skating rotate juicer
oh Big Fish broke his webcam
oh Diane Dan Dan Brooks webcam oh
nothing better than that
all right let's go here and here
here
I feel like I have to play two four
and then try to go D5 quickly
um I can go 95
yeah I don't like this actually
I feel like I have a lot of
potential in my position but I can't
quite figure out a way to harness it
okay let's try D5 Knight before I'll go
Queen B1
Ed I think I'll go A3
how many of you in this chat are old
enough to vote for me
I think most of us are over 16. that's
is that the voting age
I think it's 16.
18 18. oh yeah 18. sorry 16 is driving
tells you how much how in touch I am
with politics
no I've I have but
not when I was 18.
that is also true
wait no no no no [ __ ] he's actually
I'm gonna make a move I really don't
want to get this into some scramble
he allows Bishop F6
[Music]
I mean 18 makes sense
for voting I think your brain is
formed enough to for you to make your
decision
you know I'm kind of playing by
intuition here it's a very dangerous
position
foreign
foreign
[Music]
okay he's gonna go rugby one again now
foreign
what's there's only there's only the
farmer in front how about just a blood
smash
how about just enjoy play yes but okay
I mean it was just a game I don't know
if it was that dirty I was just playing
he outplayed me but he lost some time
oh Donald Trump got banned
what else is new
okay 58
.
foreign
[Music]
yeah I mean Donald Trump didn't even
subscribe come on that's just cheap
that's just cheap
magnet
foreign
[Music]
I've just like that's literally all I'm
saying it's like oh my God
oh my God
yeah
okay wait this has to be freaking
winning
okay I have a draw
hmm
no Knight F1 looks totally winning but
it's not obvious
okay I'm gonna go for it
Queen E3
is that was that winning
maybe not Rook 8d8
all right
it's ready for 22 made
to Kobe 95 for the prime
yeah I'm gonna play this interesting one
maybe bishop G5 was better I don't know
hmm
yeah it's kind of forcing the phone out
of the game
I have five I'm very ambitious
I don't know why I'm playing so crappy
with white I'm playing Super well with
black but I'm playing very strange for
the way
okay not to say we can't hold this I
think
okay he takes I was not expecting that
it makes sense
okay I'll play with the pawn just to
keep the square controlled
yeah I'm getting destroyed here this is
not over but it's not good
wow that was a bad opening choice
if he goes before
I feel like I have options there no
before it's not dangerous
okay this looks tempting
oh Knight C4 almost works
maybe like this
the problem is he's got like oh [ __ ]
oh that's a dagger I'd miss that move
yeah he he was clearly playing that for
a while
um okay I took up the exchange
I have a couple ways to do that
maybe he misses but if he takes to the
king I'm not even worse but
he won't take
I have some chances but
I definitely have some chances here but
it does look pretty low
okay 93
oh C4 almost freaking works
wait maybe it does
because if Rook D4 I have Knight F3 now
I should be a draw
the problem is it's very oh no no I
should have maybe gone H4 no let's go
let's go up
you know let's be careful because you
might miss a fork
[Music]
yeah I was afraid to find that
um
foreign
Fortress
foreign
that is fortunate
is very fortunate
yeah he has enough time I don't even
think I could have done anything
okay he has enough time
I don't know if I could have saved the
Knight there
oh it's lost it's actually just lost
King F1 is a draw but okay King D1 is so
natural
yeah probably would have flagged me soon
I did all of that to draw and then one
last move
I would have drawn for well no 11
seconds 22 I probably would have lost
yeah rookie 6 and King G2 King G3 is
crazy
foreign
that was also not the move I'm screwing
everything up
it was Knight fd7 no I'm just busted
it's Knight fc7
we have to play at five
foreign
there
why did I play E5 automatically
who knows oh
not sure why he allowed B6
I guess he what's up Jack I guess he
what is he going for
I think I can go F4
probably not I probably should go here
first
he wants to bury my pieces but
I don't know
who the hell knows queen of seven
where will wait this this looks very
loose
all right he's flying this seems very
loose
I see what is aiming for
this I don't think I'm gonna survive
this
he takes her the night I thought it
would take with the queen
I wants to play like this
[Music]
I hate these types of positions
I feel like I get outplayed here by
strong players
yeah this king's Indian positions you
have to be like incredibly precise with
black
okay I need a bathroom breakout for this
game
you recovery was good
I've got a Time Advantage it's nice
wait this this is this looks very wrong
C1 Knight G3
I don't know let's find out
if H5 I'll go Bishop F7 I thought
going for the fun age 60 has its true
okay
I can play
this is such a
complicated position
there's H6 Bishop has six
Queen D3 I guess he'll play Don't Go H6
let's just follow up though maybe he
doesn't even know
if Queen D3 I'll go Queen F3 quickly
pressure on him
okay wait oh
no it ain't gonna cut it I saw that I
saw that yeah
okay quick break I'll be right back
I'll be right back guys
let's go back to E4
what's up
and this is really good for back
you play Belgrade Gambit but hang on a
second time Bishop D3 and white is
totally winning here now he Castle he
play H3 and okay by Tanya White playing
totally without risk here but hang on a
second Knight takes E7 and Bishop G5 and
white white totally winning here
that was pretty good one that was
actually a really good one
um I was one of my better local
Impressions I think
crayon
you love saying hang on
Lenny G thank you for the subscription
very impressive appreciated
what does mean
in Russian it doesn't mean anything it's
not a word
hang on oh
let me hang on
yeah Magnus is Magnus
I'm actually in trouble here
what else is in there right
wait why am I why am I worse I should be
better out of the Belgrade and when you
play like this
you got sacked upon
there's 95 I'm just screwed
somewhere I messed up I should look this
line up
scared of this move
thank you for our sour grape for the
prime
oh but now I think I'm okay
I have some calm okay
eat eat
um let's go
eat eat eat eat
um shoot what do I do here I have five
takes I guess in Queen C3
and then rookie one
okay I have very nice pieces but I'm
down to pawn
maybe b4a4 B5
it's all very meh
she's 304 would be nice
I know it was exactly in which direction
this game is going oh oh yeah there we
go
there we go
do one maybe
I need a second exchange here
so they're very very complicated
position but
I guess he can take D2 oh
Bishop G7 Queen G7 yeah
I didn't do it
and blundered him
once again
here
what's truly amazing is E4 at the end
very unfortunate
Mia Z4 on the end otherwise I'd be I'd
have chances
and a nice game wow
forget where I went wrong
it's already worse here
[Music]
apparently
all the way back no it's just worse A6
is this prep I guess it's the top engine
move
I guess I should play rookie one but
I don't know
okay let's win two in a row and get to
10 15. 10-5
yeah he just he played that game
like an engine
I don't think I had much of a chance
what is this
this is some garbage
I know this is a bad line but I have no
idea how to punish I'm just gonna play
it simple
I mean I can't with white I'm just worse
every game somehow
because I have no line against the pet
shop that's the problem
and I'm already worse
I'm already worse this is gonna go D4
I have to try to prevent it
actually
I don't know it's pretty fast
don't blunder
I don't mind this position
oh [ __ ] is this move
I'm very fortunate move Knight A4
about which I'd be better
just go back
E4 very ambitious move
okay I can't take I guess I'm gonna
trust him
25 might walk into F4 in the future but
on the other hand
concretely it might work out because if
Queen C2 then I can already take
and if rookie c2i can also take weight
now suddenly he's
in some trouble I think
he does work D4
wow
I have 96
maybe just G5 to stop F4
foreign
I like the look of H5 and then G4
or maybe even H4
oh the pawn saying
92
95 F4 GF GF
when she's to reach right now some
dangerous Queen c77
so complicated
wait what
oh my gosh it's Queen yeah Queen g33
um he just has very big comp for the
[Music]
change I guess
I just have to play very active here
yeah I have I don't like these types of
positions in time pressure
okay we're up on time
Knight D4 I'll go quickly Rook G8
Knight C6 Rook g397 or G2 King g297
okay definitely Rook G8 oh don't cook an
H4
um
oh crud
oh no
Wonder this move
oh God
foreign
how scary
that's a I had to make a run for it like
in the middle of that board
I'm just gonna freaking go Queenie too
F5 so sloppy
I did this against Fabi
in a pro Chester game and I was getting
crushed
I made this exact mistake again
it's still equal but
I'm getting diddly squat with the white
pieces
again
I don't want to allow G5 and that H5 so
I'm gonna go H3 just got out playing
from an equal end game
foreign
's mate
it's obviously dead equal
he's dead equal but
okay let's drop it back I don't know why
exactly but maybe
really
Riley
so you want to take
do I not understand anything about
positional chat I mean yes but I guess I
don't
this has to be bad
this has to be bad
I guess he's playing for my Pawn
structure
okay let's take
oh my God
okay let's go here
I guess it's about equal
gabium
whatever it is
okay F3
Mosaic is
Bishop A6 maybe next
I don't know what's happening
I don't have an iota of idea
foreign
[Music]
exactly
freaking pepper Queen
but you know where he gets that from he
gets that from this famous Spanish
commentator who did that with the Kobe
Bryant shots
of course you found an amazing idea
yeah
maybe he'll blunder his Bishop
yeah this is a little lemon zando
fa50 and you know hablo Espanola
muy biano
d6o
I don't know misto this this movo
not good
okay let's go here
yo sorry Americano hablo
El Espanola
El Rococo
I'll just blunder other Rocco
and we will winnow the pawn o with
Bishop G10
this almost sounds like Pig Latin igp
whatever or people say okay let's not
lose on taimo
because it'll be very saggio
oh [ __ ] oh um let's go here
foreign
this is an easy easy winner
fast hello
wonder of the
we know the Gamo
hi kavito
side Joe
could be out and lay
and now we have 100 to 5-0 what the
score of the game up you know what I got
that from is the uh famous movie Latin
American
oh sorry online American
um National Lampoon's European
vacation from the 80s
um
there was a scene from that movie so
basically it's about this so Chevy Chase
stars and it's about this family that
you know they haven't they have an
American vacation too they go to Europe
and they're like typical American
as
so at various points they try to speak
other languages and at one point the
daughter calls Pan Am the airline
and she's like she tries to speak
Italian like information
and she says Pan Am Pano ammo
they'll understand they'll understand
that
I've seen a million movies come on
just because Danny Danny wrench
you know Danny Danny likes to
pretend that I haven't seen I haven't
seen my share of movies
in a position of kind of Sako here
to be honest though
[Music]
so
[Music]
I also had this this is very elaborate
inside joke but I did something similar
with my friend
so there's a GM named vladislav kovalev
who's from Belarus
so we kind of became friends he was
playing in St Louis
so we were hanging out and stuff and he
didn't speak English so I would
we'd go go ahead and eat and stuff and
then we would do this thing where in
Lithuanian
there's certain
like endings to words and we would add
that to Russian words and it would sound
funny
but it's hard to explain
that's a bad film it's a great film what
are you talking about
stop Taco [ __ ] oh
okay I'm just busted here
no this is resigns he just destroyed me
totally destroying you where did I even
go wrong
I made totally natural moves the entire
game totally natural moves the entire
game
we're gonna have to give up the exchange
oh he goes there
[Music]
I don't understand how this got so bad
I'm right after I have seen turkowski
movies and I'm not Russian
but I nonetheless have seen turfowsky
movies
yeah so I have congratulated though his
hasso for his birthday out
I think he's spending time with his
Familia oh
my blunder I was freaking stupid Gamo
yeah let's go here trying to stay afloat
in this position
stay afloat yeah
no I'm American
foreign
is somehow I'm surviving as usual
um let's take go and Takeo
sacrifice is it the piso and get us an
attack on the Kingo
Haso is
it's funny how everybody's into it now
32 or so
you can look it up on on the Wikipedia
on his Pedro
foreign
should have take over the other
pieceo but now his time oh is kind of
low on timer
and he's really a struggalo I might have
swindled though
um we take oh and we get winning and
then Gamo
rookie 5-0
[Music]
swindello
[Music]
thank you
[Music]